we talk about mental health all the time
and the problem with the term mental
health is it's we treat it like it's a
goal that if you're anything other than
perfect there's something wrong with you
right which of course is nonsense right
that if if you're anything other than
happy all the time then then you're then
you're struggling with your mental
health well know we know when we when we
when we do physical fitness sometimes
your muscles hurts sometimes you have a
good workout sometimes you have a bad
workout sometimes you're strong
sometimes you're weak sometimes you got
a ton of sleep and you can't work out
sometimes you got no sleep and you're
like on fire you have the best run of
your life and we don't call we there's
no goal it's Fitness like it's something
you're constantly working on I think I
stopped calling it mental health and I
started calling it mental Fitness and so
having emotions having a down day being
depressed you know be feeling lonely
like all of these things are fine and
they're totally healthy if you get stuck
in any one of them that's a problem but
by the way if you get stuck in happiness
that's a problem too you know and and so
I think we have to work on our mental
Fitness um which is learning how to have
feelings learning how to just in be in
our
feelings um because I think we've set up
an unrealistic expectation for ourselves
that if you have a negative feeling
there's something wrong with you and if
you have a negative feeling turns out
you're
human um and I think the biggest skill
that's lacking uh in all of that is uh
learning how to ask for help um that
when we do have negative feeling where
the first thing we should be do is
reaching out to a friend we don't and I
have a rule with my friends and all my
friends know this which is no crying
Alone um and I've had some people who
are well-known entrepreneurs who you
know many of your class will know and
we've had experiences where the phone
rings and they say can I talk to you go
of course what's on what's going on and
they start crying because that's the
rule no crying alone and we lean on each
other very very heavily because none of
us is stupid enough to believe we can do
this thing called life or
entrepreneurship or career by ourselves
just not that good not that strong um
and so um talking talking about anxiety
that that episode really helped frame
some of the stuff that uh that I work
through